and he came home and they stayed married
and they never got divorced and when I
think of traditional women that's who I
think of because she would rather die
than leave her man and like how many
women have that mindset of like
she didn't get mad that he cheated she
didn't throw it in his face she didn't
get angry over it and always bring it
back up later she genuinely tried to
find a solution understood where he was
coming from and wanted to keep the
family together no matter what now I'm
not saying you know they had a perfect
marriage or We should strive for that
but I just think like that mentality is
so rare nowadays it's like it's like
they see Instagram and they think
something's going to be better on the
other side and a lot of times it's not
about me sometimes from the where we're
sitting now the coaches here we must
know some old person
that's done that because I know a couple
and I actually know that this this guy
and I always saw him with his wife
and um together and I think I said oh
he's gone somebody said where is he gone
I said oh
so where's your husband assistant
where's your husband that's not my
husband
I was just like okay I said someone
what's their problem I said she got
everybody said that's not uh that's my
husband that's not his wife so what do
you mean they're always together it's
got door keys goes to the house we've
all up into the house you know he's like
another home and then I met the wife
the wife knew all about it but that was
her husband
and if the wife steps in and if they
happen to meet like so they were going
to a funeral and the wife was there
she had to step back and hold her place
and because the wife was the wife she
didn't they all had basically Separate
Lives you know the wife's still got the
family home grandkids and everything and
he goes and comes but their wife's got a
they always have to show respect because
she's the wife and there's no way on
Earth that she'd ever give him a divorce
that's her husband her house her
whatever he does outside but he's there
for his grandkids he's there for the
things that husband's supposed to do
but just because something's a tradition
does that mean it should be uphold
forever just because it's a tradition I
believe in death to us part I believe
that if I got married somebody has to
die
when we were the other somebody else I'm
a firm believer in that and I that's my
husband if you if I was married and you
want to step out you can step out and
step in a lot she's like at the end of
the day
I'm I'm not I'm not getting divorced I
mean do you think it's wise to do what's
worked or try something new
um I don't think worked is the right
terminology though I feel I feel like
the word is
um
tolerated I feel like there's a lot of
tolerating going on because some things
are tradition I don't necessarily think
it's worked because back in back in the
day like my grandparents for example it
was the same concept there was no such
thing as divorce and I know I know
certain couples go through
disrespect and a lot of abuse and a lot
of bad things but you tolerate it
because you don't get divorced I feel
like at some point you have to break
that barrier of okay so you're not
you're not respecting me as an
individual or as the mother of your
children or as your wife but I must deal
with this because we got married
what's better for the children separate
households or one household if if it's a
toxic household and there's abuse going
on separate because children what's
better figuring out how to get along or
continuing to be toxic it takes two to
be toxic 100 but sometimes there isn't
there is no repair sometimes things are
Beyond repair I I think that's a choice
you can't if someone's screaming at you
and argue it's your choice to scream
back 100 but you can also fall out of
love with someone based on repeated
Behavior someone might not adapt or
someone is compromise it has to go is
love a feeling or a choice
loves the feeling
you think so yeah I feel like you can't
suck because sometimes you don't want to
love someone but you do if it was a
choice you would decide I don't love you
anymore but it's not always that simple
do you think your your parents always
felt like they loved you
like when yeah like I don't know when I
was a kid there was times I would scream
out of temper tantrums you think my mom
in that moment
just felt love for me
deep deep down yeah but I have a face
honey she used to beat me with a spoon
but out of love it was out of love
though yeah but that's what I mean like
she might not have felt like she loved
me but her choices proved that she did
and I think it's the same thing with a
family like I mean in my opinion anyway
I think you know you can feel a certain
way about your husband you might hate
him at some I mean even wouldn't
Michelle Obama came out and said she
hated Barack for 10 years okay so in a
situation where you've got a husband and
a wife and the husband goes out and he
goes to work and he provides for the
family however you come to him every
night and he beats his wife and then he
beats his kids so should that woman deal
with that and tolerate that for the rest
of her life because she decided to get
married I don't forget I said once
there's no right once nobody's life's in
danger okay
it's really interesting like women
always bring up abuse like we're just
getting beat left and right hmm when the
numbers don't show that the majority of
men are abusing women so you know that's
not that's an exception it's not the
rule
um yeah I think if your life's in danger
I would agree but I actually would still
um
part of me like part of me still thinks
that you should separate not divorce
so so then was I don't know but I'm not
going to die on that Hill I haven't
thought that one I'm like don't don't
quote me okay it's like I'm gonna say
that for now I might change my mind
later okay
but
it's a paper it's a piece of paper as
well I know isn't it marriage like I
think
now it is I think yeah because
everything that you say in your vows
um you know loving whatever whatever
that's that's someone's actions getting
divorced is it's the paper it's the
legal whatever that word is yeah where a
relationship is something you have to
work on like most people that get
divorced they usually have some form of
relationship sometimes another the love
doesn't die it just evolve somewhere
different like I'm divorced I got
married I was with my um ex-husband for
15 years from 17 onwards and then we got
married in the last year I proposed to
him just because I thought it was the
right thing to do
um and then we we broke up and we don't
really talk we've got a terrible
relationship so you waited 16 years to
get married 15 years 15 years yeah then
you got married
and then you broke up divorced after
yeah yeah because we shouldn't have got
married we were trying to do the right
thing for our children
um but you know we just grew apart as
people it wasn't for any real reason I
grew apart couldn't you grow back
together I know because if you grew one
way you could grow the other one well
the thing is Boo like I was 17 when I
got with him I was a child which I mean
that was a 38 year old woman I don't
feel any form of attraction to him at
all the way he talks walks dresses his
whole thing with two completely
different people so you left because you
weren't attracted to him no we left
because we're just two different people
on two different paths because I'm just
thinking I might like my mom met my dad
when she was 17 and I mean there were
times where they didn't like each other
and she probably like you know would
have said the same thing at one at some
points in their marriage but they just
stuck it out and like and now they're
really cute my dad just took her on the
cutest thing because they're getting old
I just wanted to know because I don't
believe that women should ask men yeah I
think that's just the Daniel as well
yeah why did you ask him
um do you think because I find that if a
man's gonna marry he's going to be like
yes within the first say three four
years after that it's just because he
feels pressurized by Society we've got
kids or the woman said we've been
together for how many years now you're
gonna make an honest woman of me and
yeah no it's a big mistake personally
like I don't think any woman should
propose to a man I think a man should
take his wife and that's the first
mistake to make
um and also just trying to for me I
wanted him to feel secure in our
relationship because I've always been
quiet not always but I was a little bit
more bigger energy than him and he was a
little he's a Colombian man you know
they think the woman should be and I'm a
British kind of I was right my mom was
single like was raised to be ourselves
really hard and I'm a creative so
there's all these culture clashes as
well
um but yeah you know I think personally
not everything is about marriage like we
got together when we was children we
don't know ourselves I didn't know
myself as a woman he didn't know himself
as a man so after those three years
we're still what 21 22 we had our first
child we're trying to open up a business
like we weren't a factor of you know um
where it needs to be is something that
kind of felt natural but it wasn't if
you didn't get married would you still
going together no no
the vibe just changed the energy just
changes you want different things from
different people like he's happy to have
a nine to five I don't want that women
always seems to outgrow the men
especially the artists especially the
artists that even book writers musicians
painters or something like that they
move in a different Circle and then all
of a sudden like they're there and and
they see the land is there it's not on
my level anymore or they've outgrown him
or he doesn't understand me I'm mixing
in different circles I've got different
Vibes yeah it wasn't that but I I
respect did you feel like that that he
was holding back your career at all yeah
a thousand percent like you know I
remember I had a major audition he said
if you go for that me and you're
breaking up and that's the audition for
big brother and I got three Big
Brother's like you don't know it's a
reality show it's a reality show and
people about 10 people going to a house
and they get watched 24 7 whatever and I
got through quite far and he's like if
you go on it then basically it's either
me or the show obviously is it a dating
show no it's just it's like a social
experiment where they put like 12
different people different personalities
into one house for three months
yeah yeah it's hilarious it's cool
um so yeah and you know he always oh
you're an attention seeker this year
that like he was putting me down from a
young age and not appreciating and
respecting who I was as a person
um but that was his own insecurities
because as much as yeah I'm an artist
and flamboyant and I'm also a loyal
woman I I appreciate and love loyalty
and respect and sacredness and the fact
that I could go out and you know
perform but then come home to my husband
would have been a dream come true for me
but his own ego for whatever reasons
wherever he's come from his environment
he didn't allow it so if he didn't do
that would you do you think it would
have worked out 100 yeah if he would
have appreciated me for who I was as a
person so it sounds like he wanted you
to act more traditional in a way and
yeah you were more modern yeah and then
that's what ended the marriage was he
was trying to make you into something
that you're not basically so I'm not a
traditional woman this is what I've
realized this is the conversation I'm a
modern woman so yeah that was the reason
you just realized that
as you're not talking
a penny with my husband still to this
day if I was a traditional woman
whenever women say Traditional Values
they always say cooking feeling looking
after those and men can do that easy
whenever they say Traditional Values and
we get to hear something that men agree
on and
women always say cooking cleaning
looking out for the kids everyone just
want someone to have his back and to
enhance him
that's it enhance him grow with him
that's it
but I was glad that you realized that
you weren't traditional because the way
you were saying because
you know when I realized is when you
said oh he said if I was going to go on
Big Brother hmm
that was finished and I wouldn't but I
didn't go on Big Brother
I missed the opportunity like oh you
listened to them yeah of course I did oh
right yeah if you didn't end up getting
remarried do you think you would regret
it
say it again babe if you didn't end up
getting remarried so if you're if you're
70 60 by yourself would you regret
leaving him yeah because my next part
that I'm with we don't actually
physically have to get married if he
marries himself to me and we're loyal
when we live that way cool but we don't
have to go to a church or go to a
registry office and sign the papers for
the government no but I want to find my
man that's loyal to me I'm loyal to him
that I can give myself to that's what
I'm on no but I'm saying like if that
didn't happen would you because we were
talking about earlier that a lot of
women regret it because they don't end
up fine I'm not saying that'll happen
I'm just saying if if you were in that
situation do you think you'd regret it
yeah well I'm hoping I don't stay single
for the rest of my life
um yeah because I don't hate the guy I
think if you put in if you put an effort
into anything anything could work out so
I mean I actually I still love the guy
so so in a way did you feel like you
could do better than that relationship a
thousand percent but that's only because
I got into a relationship as a child as
a teenager and not as a woman that knows
herself 12 and 17 is an adult I don't
think 17 is an adult not at all 17 is
another all depends on your mindset
exactly I had my son at 17. and I'd be I
had to be an adult so if I was with a
man and get in a relationship you'd have
to be an adult we played the adult you
know what I'm saying yeah that's what I
mean yeah okay that I didn't play yeah
we had the household we had the children
we did we was doing the whole thing you
know what I'm saying but at the same
time I was a child because I'm
emotionally unintelligent so when the
The War of the World actually do start
to come up to you you don't know how to
deal with them properly and that's my
own experience but didn't your mum help
you
um well my mum's come from relationship
after relationship come from a broken
family so I've had to break the
generational curse even I'm not with him
but I'm not out here sleeping with Tom
Dick and Harry I'm selling but like I'm
holding myself down because I don't need
to be doing casual sex and I'm waiting
for my king so in order to wait for my
king I have to hold myself
do you think that men generally want to
wait for women that have had children
already because I've just talked to guys
about this and it's kind of like if you
already have a child no they don't yeah
or they don't like do you think that's a
good strategy no the men don't want
women that have got children
unfortunately because the thought of it
bringing up someone's kid or whatever
but my children they're not children
they're young men no I meant the
celibacy like it sounded like you were
gonna have guys like wait for sex
because no they're not waiting I'm
waiting so I'm not in I'm not in any
form of relationship like I don't even
understand you're focused on the career
yeah and myself though because I don't I
don't like to just let any guy inside of
me because that don't make me feel good
so it's not just about the career
because I'm still I'm single I want a
man
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible